camera would be we all fell in love with  Quicksilver in the last film and we  wanted to find a unique and interesting  way to take his powers from going to the  extraction the mansion is imploding so I  try to get everybody out  we use some of the most sophisticated  filming technology in creating this very  very elaborate sequence we use the  Phantom for the slow motion the phantom  camera runs 3,000 frames per second so  it can freeze real time and to put that  into perspective something that happens  in just a blink of an eye turns into  about 15 seconds in order to get our  timing right we're hoping to move our  camera close to 90 miles per hour as it  goes through the explosion visual  effects life there's so many more  elements now everything's frozen and  they're flying through the air the real  challenges their safety is is landing  the close proximity to each other  the guys been rehearsing for the most of  the week and I think we're ready to go  here we go three two one go